just
take a step back to something you
brought up earlier the inelasticity of
pricing
is it uh from a perspective of the
dealers
whether we're talking about cigarettes
or maybe
venturing slightly into the illegal
realm
you know of people who sell drugs
illegally they also have an economics to
them
that they set prices and all those kinds
of things
does addiction allow you to mess with
the nature
of pricing like so
i i kind of assume that you meant that
there's a correlation between
things you're addicted to and the
inelasticity of the price
so you can jack up the price is is there
something interesting to be said
both for legal drugs and illegal drugs
about the kind of price
games you can play um
because the consumers of the product are
addicted
right i mean i think you just described
it yeah you can jack up the price
and you know some people are going to
drop off
but the people you know and it's not
dichotomous because you could just
consume less
but some people are going to consume
less and the people that are most
addicted are going to keep
you know um i mean you see this they're
going to keep you know purchasing so you
see this with cigarettes and so
it's interesting when you interface this
with policy like in one respect
heavily taxing cigarettes is a good
thing we know it keeps
you know um adolescents particularly
price sensitive
so you definitely people smoke less and
especially kids smoke less when you keep
cigarette prices high and you tax the
hell out of them
um but one of the downsides you've got
to balance and keep in mind
is that you disproportionately have
working class
poor people and then you get into a
point where someone's spending
you know order of their paycheck on so
they're gonna smoke no matter what
and uh basically because they're
addicted they're gonna smoke no matter
what and you're just
yeah you're taxing their existence right
so you're making it worse for
if they don't if they are completely
inelastic you're actually making that
person's life worse
because we know that that by by
interfering with the amount of money
they have
you're interfering with the other um
pro-social the potential
competitors to smoking you know um and
we know that
when someone's in more impoverished
environments and they have less sort of
non-drug
alternatives you know the more likely
they're gonna stay
addicted so you know is there data
this is interesting from a scientific
perspective
of those same kind of games in illegal
drugs
sort of because that's where most drugs
i was i mean i don't know maybe you can
correct me but it seems like most drugs
are currently illegal and so
but they're still in economics to them
obviously right that's the drug war and
so on
is there data on the setting of prices
or like how good are the business people
running
the selling of drugs uh that are illegal
are they
all the same kind of rules apply from a
behavioral economics perspective
i think so i mean they're basically that
whether they're crunching the numbers or
not they're basically sensitive to that
demand curve and they're doing the
the the same thing that businesses do in
in a legal market and
you know you want to sell as much of a
product to get as much
money you're looking more at the total
income so if you jack the price
a little bit you're going to get some
reduction in consumption but it may be
that the total amount of money that you
rake in is going to be more than then
it's going to overcompensate for that so
you're willing to take okay i'm going to
lose 10 of my customers
but i'm getting more perce you know more
than enough to compensate from that from
the extra money from the people who
still are buying
so i think they're more you know and
especially when we get to the lower i
wouldn't be surprised if people are
crunching those numbers and looking at
demand curves maybe at the
you know at the really high levels of
the you know up the chain where the
cartels and one i don't know
i that wouldn't surprise me at all but i
think it's probably even more implicit
at the at the lower levels where um
something he brought up drug policy i
will say that i for for years now it's
been this kind of
unquestioned goal um by for example the
the drug czar's office um in the u.s to
to
make the price of illegal drugs as high
as possible without this kind of nuanced
approach that
um yeah if you make you know for some
people if you
you know if you make the price so high
you're actually making things
worse i mean i'm all about reducing the
problems associated with drugs and drug
addictions and part of that is the
are more direct consequences of those
drugs themselves and but a whole lot is
what you get from
indirectly and and you know sort of the
inc both for the individual and for
society society so
like making a poor person who doesn't
have enough money for their kids making
them even poorer so now you've made
their their chil children's future worse
because they're growing up in deeper
poverty because you've essentially
levied a tax
onto this person who's heavily uh
addicted
um but then it's at the societal level
you know so
everything we know about the drug war in
terms of the the heavy criminalization
and filling up
prisons and reducing employment and
educational opportunities
which in the big picture we know are the
things that
in a free market compete against some of
the worst problems
of addiction is actually having
educational and employment opportunities
but when you get give someone a felony
for example um
you're pretty much guaranteeing they're
never going to go very high on the
economic ladder
and so you're making drugs a better
reward
for that person's future
you